hello and welcome to the lobby
gamespot's weekly video game chat show
every tuesday at two p.m. pacific right
here on gamespot com live it's also on
twitch or hello if you're watching this
on demand gamespot com or YouTube my
name is Daniel Dwyer i'm the host of
today's proceedings joined as ever by
mr. christopher waters hey Danny how are
you doing my friend Oh gearing up to go
down south yeah this is a one day week
MLK Day Monday lobby day Tuesday San
Antonio the same residue perp XL yeah
and and you guys are gonna go there hit
us up on Twitter we can hang out
absolutely walk go to yellow sounds like
many people going we'll see all the
indie games there in like 30 minutes yep
45 maybe we'll see what's gonna happen
but there are actual boxed retail games
also coming out at least I think
resident evil HD remaster has a box
retail version but who better than mr.
kevin van or the reviewer of that video
game for gamespot com to come on and
tell us is there a mux copy of resin I
don't know yet i honestly don't know i
think so it came in codes oh really oh I
think there is this last time you bought
a box copy of the game a boxed copy of
the game uh bought destiny Bayonetta 2
okay I did that's no been here 20 mario
kart for me there you go the wii u so
i'll keep it a real yeah but we have you
here today because we're gonna do a new
feature today on the lobby called ask
the reviewer where we ask the reviewer
question this better review that it this
is this is scary is the scary is this
like the comment sections come to life
this is uh no comment resilience for
that I have picked out some choice at
critiques and questions from the
comments section on gamespot com and
also from the Twitter where we put a
post edge on my Twitter at your twitter
on on gamespot as well so I picked out a
couple you've had you say about about
the game and these are just a sort of a
selection of the various okay okay the
people of you ready k yeah yeah raji
water go for it what you give the game t
i gave it i gave it a seven out of ten i
said it was good it's really not very
good 2 that's 3 2.5 better than resident
evil 6 oh this game that's this upward
trend Capcom it's so much better than
resume / 60 I'm gonna get into these
question is oh yeah
and grin 89 asked a question which
actually a lot of people were wondering
about because there's some here say
about this are there still Jill
sandwiches they change some of the games
that mostly notable as far as I know it
was changed in the game Qbert like that
was that that goes back to the original
but it didn't make its way i I thank
into the gamecube version and what this
game is is it's just an HD remaster of
the gamecube version so when your
resolve all the dialogue as far as i can
tell me no jill sandwich no master of
unlocking there's an achievement called
master of unlocking already yeah but as
far as i know there's no dialogue that
calls her master what a damn shame and
to that end call Tyler called asks how
do you balance reviewing the technical
parts of a remaster and the original
experience and I guess this kind of an
even weirder thing here because you're
reviewing a remastered version yeah they
remastering so well how do you like is
it difficult to sort of critique again
based on like 2015 standards it's you
know I think any time you review uh you
know re-release it's always kind of
tricky because there's a lot of stuff
going on there's the there's the issue
of how do you review a classic you know
cuz I don't think of it I don't think of
reviewing a remaster or re-release as
just you know a retro game review you
know I'm not pretending that it's you
know it's 2002 now and that all of those
years didn't happen so I think it is
important to talk about like okay you've
never played resident evil one you know
what are you going to get out of this if
you don't have the nostalgia for it and
sometimes you have to remember too that
the way you remember things sometimes is
really hard to go back to games like you
think it's a masterpiece and then you go
back to that silly little thing you
played on the NES all those years ago a
like oh god this is crap and what was I
thinking umm so so it you know it's it's
balancing you know how good is the game
now after all that time has passed how
good is the remaster itself like did
they do a good job with the extras that
they threw in there other considerations
to like other remasters you know like I
think of halo yeah which chris you
reviewed last year like some of that
visual stuff is
markable like there was a lot of stuff
that went into that I wouldn't say that
this it lives in that same category of
remasters it's it's very good the
updates in the sense that it it makes
the game I said this in the review it
makes the game look like you remember it
looking as opposed to what it really
looked like and I think that's a triumph
in and of itself if for instance a
gamecube re-release never existed if
this was the first time that capcom had
gone back to this this beloved game and
this is how it look like that you think
perhaps it would have been more
impressive along with it would probably
have more impact absolutely but it
there's also the issue of okay so you
had the 2002 uh remake which really is
for all intents and standards like
intents and purposes a remake as opposed
to just sprucing up you know there were
new areas and new puzzles and lots of
things that were different and brand new
visuals and there was a giant leap
between what Resident Evil One was and
what remake on gamecube was in a
relatively short period of time in a
shorter period of time that has happened
between remake yes now yeah twelve years
more and so there there's a little bit
of that disappointment in there when
it's like okay there would you know the
first time around it was much bigger
bigger change than it is now but when
all things consider this game really
holds up there are some things that are
annoying now that we're honestly
annoying then so 2000 Lexi I've got a
couple of questions about those and
light runner trip love 07 asks I'm a
huge fan of the original remake on
gamecube and i understand that it's time
the invitations were still somewhat
there however i honestly don't
understand why the devs didn't add the
element of being able to see what's in
front of you so one of the things that
you could say that that's something
that's inherently important in that game
but say one of the things that irk you
was the loading screen just still there
with the doors every that again so how
you sort of say what elements they
should keep for having like touchstones
in the game and what they shouldn't
change we were presumably a first-person
mode might just change what resident
evil is or at least the ability to write
I mean we're having this discussion
before I mean it residi will
for sort of proved like here's what you
can do to change take this into a new
territory and III don't know like I
didn't expect them to turn this into
resident evil 4 I think that's beyond
what you should expect for a remaster I
still have to make sure my expectations
are within what we know a product to be
and I didn't expect this to be like a
resident evil 4 type reimagining of
Resident Evil One I think that's a
completely different undertaking it
sounds awesome and now I want to play
that but I didn't really expect that to
change what we were having this
discussion earlier about like what could
you reasonably expect to change and
there are a couple things that I think
would keep the essence of resin evil one
but maybe switch to maybe waste a little
less time like I'm sort of okay with the
camera angles for the most part like it
does all those fix camera angles they
allow them to set up each shot kind of
like you do in a film like a prop master
doesn't a film where everything is in
exactly the place it's meant to go and
so they can do that in videogame form a
resident evil with with all of these
fixed shots of course the downside is
that their annoyances especially with
the new control scheme which lets you
get around using the analog stick jab
pointing in the direction you want to go
but the problem is of course when the
camera switches and a great example is a
puzzle that people probably know where
you have to flip a switch the wall start
going in and you have to run around and
push this statue and stuff so there's
this puzzle and then when you're when
you're doing that the camera changes
like four times as you're just going
around the corner trying to do this and
you're ever timing changes and you have
to sort of adjust how you're doing
that's like there's a time limit let me
just get this done and you can use the
old control scheme but yeah there there
are some inherent like kind of issues
with the camera that happen up and but
that doesn't bother me so much I think
you don't keep the camera angles
whatever i think that's that's fine but
then on the other hand you get some
things that kind of do get annoying like
I don't know that the the door opening
animations are really adding all that
much at this stage maybe the first time
you do it but after a while like when
you're in a 30 second bit of gameplay
and you have to you're doing all this
backtracking and suddenly it's like open
three minutes of door
three minutes of walking three minutes
of earth through seconds i'm sorry i
said minutes 3 seconds that's a long
door open outs like three seconds of
door three seconds of walking after a
while that can kind of like you know
maybe maybe they could have been cut it
adds up to be a significant percentage
of your time the game is watching a door
and speaking of things that perhaps you
would have liked them to cause and this
is a kicking off a bit on twitter at the
moment Derek human asked a very good
question yo I know what's with the boob
physics was not in the gamecube version
if so why leave it in and I saw you have
a discussion with somebody on Twitter a
I did because I sort of confirmed that
that was I because I thought that what
was it like that because I noticed when
I was playing it wasn't anything that
stood out to me a whole lot like you
notice when the kid liked it thank you
for looping this bio right before the
before I show star so this is from me
and Peter playing and it wasn't until
not this part but this barcelo that I
was like what the hell yeah and there
are a couple of shots where where those
things really are moving a bit so and
it's something I didn't remember in the
gamecube version but then again like
memory is a funny thing right and i'm
not really a breast man yeah as it were
so I I went back and I watched a bunch
of footage of the gamecube version today
and sure enough there it was it was
always there so is that something you
think like you know 2015 perhaps were
past the point of this stuff like being
widely acceptable by gaming yeah i think
two things have happened number one is
we're just noticing stuff like that more
because it's mainly gratuitous um and I
think we're I think we're becoming more
and more conscious of what you know what
purposes are served by things like
there's no real purpose that that serves
we don't know more about Jill and
honestly that doesn't look all that
authentic or realistic for a you know a
woman in the field to just you know I I
don't know I seems like that's number
one I think we're just noticing I stuff
number two is it stage d now like
something that you played on your
gamecube and we're watching on an SD you
know TV it probably looked a lot less
flagrant too noticeable then whereas
night now you spruce it up i I don't
know i don't think that they've enhanced
those breasts in any way i just think
that now that now that it's in
we have all the glorious pixels you're
right that it's more now in HD you know
just looks like she has two bags of
water yeah out of like actual human
flora boobs yeah and things like that we
do notice that stuff more the way things
move in video is oh really we don't need
to we need three slow version of this
really just trying to appreciate the
environmental art here yet is that
lighting remaster is just she's so all
things considered I wanna get a guy one
joint right there I wasn't all that
bothered by it wasn't it really wasn't
like playing soul calibur yeah um or
dead or alive or anything it wasn't like
I was just suddenly being knocked in the
head by breasts everywhere or that's a
different video but we it's available on
xbox live in DS probably yeah I did I
did I didn't notice and it makes me
wonder you know where all the junk
physics we never seen junk fazzino with
Chris Redfield I'm sure he's got some
ample package of course real life jump
physics are really as muscley in the new
skin he does look ridiculous member when
they resident evil five stuff came at me
and his arm was like [ __ ] 12 times
the size of regular you here oh yeah I
remember here cuz that was a year we had
the biggest biceps we had a cardigan our
end of the Year voting it was Chris
Redfield it was a 50 cent from blood on
the sand where's my skull it was a
bionic commando dude Bionic Commando
these guys with just like heaps of armed
meat is actually had five nominated or
for sure is this something just cap con
love doing cuz like the logo for
resident evil 6 out of giraffe getting a
you know he getting a bit of the crotch
close yeah the bright were a giraffe
crotches yeah coming for residents a
maclee career who knows resident evil 7
beach volleyball here we go at kevin van
or thank you very much oh I'm done
there's autumn address that wasn't so
bad hey I'm gonna say the least
controversial thing I'll say all day a
bet it won't be Rick Resident Evil One
is better than resident evil 6 there you
go cat I'm sure someone in the comments
times sometimes attack
you